*wild range of excited noises*
Is it rolling?
Guys I'm here with Jon Cozart!
Yeee!
It's happening!
This is a very exciting video because
I wanted to shoot something with you for a really long time
and Diane made me privy to the information that you tweeted:
-That's funny! -It is really funny! -I'm a funny man
-I know you are! -I can do it.
I think you're hilarious, I think this is a great tweet.
So I this was a great opportunity to try a face mask for the first time.
I'm into it.
And we're not starting subtly.
We're starting with 'milky dress'.
I didn't know there were like, levels.
Like you start off with a basic face mask
and then you graduate to whatever the hell this
like vampiric sh*t is.
This is a fun guy 'cos this is a magnetic face mask.
So you put it on, you dry
and then you use a magnet to suck it off your face.
Sounds horrifying.
Also, Mamrie Hart is here
and she's allowed me to kind of use her segment that she originated 'Mask Me Anything'
so we're gonna put the face mask on
and then Twitter has sent some scandalous questions for you to answer.
Oooh, Twitter. -Are you ready?
Ooh Twitter! -Yeah, I'm prepped.
First let's get into our milky dress.
Is that what it's called??
Milky Dress.
Every good face mask comes with this many instructions for it.
I feel working already.
It is a magnet.
Ooohh wooow!
OOOOOHHHHH
That's a bizarre consistency.
Yeah it's like that magnetic sand.
I've might have seen it in infomercials.
Well today you're gonna kinda put it on your face.
So you just dip hands right in and smear it on your face.
-Legit? -Do you want me to go first?
Yeah.
Look!
Woah!
Alright, it's just like putting mud on your face.
Uh huh.
Okay, I can do that.
It's a casual activity. It feels weird!
It feels like I should eat it.
Don't!
You know.
Diane: That spatula's for sure there to put it on your face.
-Oh -No that's to clean it off the magnet.
Oh wait, no she is putting it on her face with the spatula.
Diane how much did this cost?
Diane: Like 50 something dollars
This is like $50.
You're kidding.
-I'm putting on about $14 on my face right now. -I can't believe
-Oh that's -Oh 100% better
That's how you paint it on.
Dude this is what the money buys.
That spatula's $49 and the actual face mask is 1.
Okay, now we get into the Q&A part.
Is this a gay thing?
-I Diane: It's like a foot fetish thing.
Oooohhhh my gosh of course.
You're in *laughter*
What? Am I a toe bro?
I though you were saying of course you are a toe bro.
No of course that's what it is.
Um no
No? Okay.
Actually no, when it comes to kinks I'm like
whatever your bliss is, I'll join you.
Oh.
Like I'm gonna meet you in the middle.
What a compromising kinkster you are.
-It was at VidCon. -Uh huh
Maybe three, four years ago.
I think it was Hannah Witton who introduced me to you 'cos she like
*inaudible attempt at a British accent*
Hannah is, if you don't know, British.
She doesn't have speech impediment.
Then I met you and you were like 40 feet tall.
Yeah.
And I didn't know you were 40 feet tall.
Surprise.
'Cos the videos just don't, usually you're seated or by yourself.
Right.
Here a scandalous question.
Um no.
Someone got sassy really quickly.
Yeah also, where does the stripper come from? I don't get the joke.
Because you just went out and put money in a stripper over the weekend.
Ooohhh right.
I've never out a dollar in a stripper's belt before
so you've done something I've never done.
I mean he was not wearing a belt.
We had fun and then we had more fun
and then we had too much fun
and then I was peeing on the side of the road.
It was amazing.
There was these like big ropes and a kind of saddle thing
the guys would get like a running start
and then like go over everybody with their crotch in everybody's faces.
And everyone's like freaking out.
It was like a gayer Cirque du Soleil if you can imagine that.
It was wild.
That's were Jon's been so don't expect an upload anytime soon guys.
No.
Someone wants to know:
Um....
You can say ours.
No, I mean every collab's a little awkward for me.
Just 'cos I'm like
which version of me should I try to be today.
Like what am I going for.
Maybe I have Aspergers
or maybe I'm like a complete narcissist
or maybe I'm just normal and a little anxious.
Like I just bounce around.
Like a pinball of anxiety.
I read something on a Tumblr, they were like
please tell me how to make friends in school
and please none of that just be yourself bullshit 'cos  that's not working right now
It's like, I get this.
That guy!
Ooooohhhhh!
This one's a scandalous one!
It is!
Rarely someone I know.
But you have had ones about people you know.
Yeah.
Yeah. We all have.
Mostly they're just weird, they're not like people I'm sexually attracted to.
It's like teachers that shouldn't be sexualised
but always had like the biggest breasts.
And so they'd like lean over your desk
and like point to the question and talk to you
and their boob is just like rubbing up against your cheek.
-It so.. -*laughter*
I'm sure plenty of you out there can relate to those kind of stories.
-Certainly - If you have leave it in the comments down below.
Let us know!
Who? How?
I used to think everybody who died became an angel.
So much iconography of people dying and then thier soul
like growing wings and just kinda like flying up to heaven.
But that's not biblical fellas.
That is not biblical.
-That's just a redbull commercial. -Yeah
So I guess the idea is you use this, you go close,
and it starts pulling it off and then you just kinda scrape it
off the magnet onto the paper towel. -Got it
You just go close ish to your face.
I think I used a lot and you didn't.
You did use a lot.
I just put all..this is at least $24.
*amazement*
Wow!
This really works!
What is this?!
Mamrie: *gasp* Oh my God!
Oh my God! It's pulling it straight off!
It's like just the cleanest.
Here, finger.
What?! That feels like baby skin.
It's my little baby skin.
See how much you can get if you wipe around your whole face.
Oh yeah just like
Oh my God, this is crazy.
Yeah this is
WHAT?!
For never having tried a face mask before
you can't go back to any of the normal ones now.
Yeah I know!
Oh that's what we're doing wrong.
You're supposed to wrap the magnet in a paper towel
so it collects on the paper towel. -There it is.
-It all works. - This makes so much more sense now.
Look at you!
I'm beautiful!
Unreal how clean it comes off.
This is really cool.
Mamrie's face is shook.
*face of shook*
Pull up the stock, this has to be publicly traded.
I'm investing!
And then this is so much easier that way.
We're idiots!
Oh God, this feels so nice!
No! I f*cked up!
I f*cked up!
I f*cked up so hard!
How do you feel after your first face mask Jon Cozart?
I feel good.
Ow! I feel good!
Na na na na na
I though meant ow like
all of sudden it started burning and that's where we find out -No
that you have a deep allergic reaction. -No
Well I hope you had fun in this video.
This was fun!
Thank you for being here.
Yeah!
I'm happy to have provided you with your first face mask experience.
They're not..any of them are not like this.
And thank you Mamrie for allowing me to use 'Mask Me Anything'.
Of course!
If you guys haven't checked out already, Mamrie made Jon
a very specific cocktail beverage in an episode of
'YouTubers  Deserve a Drink' over on her channel so go check that out.
Also go follow Jon on social media and subscribe to his Youtube channel
'cos at some point maybe you're going to upload something -Of course!
and it will be a surprise for everyone. -Of course.
Oh yeah, and Jon's going to be over on Hannah's channel making a Tunesday with her
so you got all kinds of videos with Jon to watch.
That is a lot of me.
Yeah so stop complaining that he's not making videos guys.
Yeah.
He's here right now. Other than that, I don't know.
Ngaaaaa!
That's my en entran end music.
Yeah. It's like a more pathetic Christopher Nolan.